Countdowns,
intimidated.
Welcome.
Please join me in welcoming our panelists today.
Um,
first right here to my right,
we have meaning leader.
She's the director,
has had a long successful directorial career spanning decades with numerous TV
shows,
which I think you've heard of.
The leftovers vanish.
John Doe,
he are among them in several film credits,
um,
including the peacemaker and one of my personal favorites,
deep impact.
Um,
then we have Justin throw,
um,
he plays Mel Wulf who was then the head of the ACL.
Ooh.
Um,
Justin's known for his work with David Lynch on Mulholland drive and in inland
empire and most recently seen as Kevin Garvey [inaudible] Garvey,
excuse me,
in Hbo is the leftovers.
Tom and the girl on the train and Dr. James Monterrey on Netflix is the maniac.
Um,
and then,
um,
we have Daniel woman,
he is the film screenwriter and the real life nephew to justice Ginsburg.
What a happy accident of birth.
Um,
so I think,
uh,
to start off with,
I love to ask you me,
how did you get involved with this project?
Well,
um,
I was given the script.
Finally,
manager,
my agent,
John 11,
Robert Court and,
uh,
our producer and Johnathan king,
also our producer,
president,
participant sent me the script and I immediately read it and felt that I had to
do it.
Yeah.
I just felt like I really understood her having,
uh,
you know,
lived through a very,
in a very deep,
in a different generation and a different industry,
you know,
live through a lot of discrimination and inequality and,
just had to fight the fight in,
in my,
in my profession,
in my world.
And I felt a commonality with Ruth being,
um,
a woman who is a mother,
is Jewish,
who's been in a long standing marriage and know what that takes.
And I,
you know,
breaking the glass ceilings in our,
in our own ways,
uh,
for generations to come.
And I just felt this is a story about a living icon,
someone who I have,
who did so much for,
for our country and changed the world as well for all of us.
And I just felt very lucky to have been able to direct this film.
Wonderful.
Well,
we,
I,
I got to see it earlier this weekend.
Um,
I think we got lucky to get to watch it and it was,
it's fantastic.
So you should all definitely check it out.
Um,
it'll be in theaters and Christmas.
so,
uh,
for Daniel,
how did the first nephew to justice Ginsburg,
um,
pretty exciting.
What were those first?
That's a first.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I think growing up,
did you realize the impact that,
um,
justice Ginsburg was having sort of in,
in the world and our country's laws,
um,
both as an attorney miss from court justice?
Was that part of sort of the dialog in your home or?
Well,
mostly I just found it confusing,
um,
because I,
I was born after all the events of this film and so people would say,
oh,
that's your aunt.
She changed the world.
I'm looking at cross like the Thanksgiving table,
and she's just very quietly,
very slowly eating her Turkey dinner.
And I'm going her really,
because I had,
you know,
I had a vision in my head.
I think I got us of what a feminist from the 70s was,
right as Gloria Steinem standing in front of a crowd,
bringing everyone to their feet.
And here's my quiet and um,
you know,
who changed the world.
And part of what I came to appreciate,
understand from running the movie is that my voice is very loud.
Um,
is that,
uh,
you know,
sustainable change takes a Gloria Steinem to,
to,
to shift the culture and it takes a Ruth Bader Ginsburg to change the laws and
the institutions.
Um,
you were,
you were quoted saying,
I'm,
one of the great joys of writing the movie was that it felt like I got to really
know where for the first time.
So what were some of the surprising things you discovered as you,
as you wrote the screenplay or as you sort of dug in and,
and,
and put this together?
Yeah,
I mean,
she's my amperage.
He's 50 years older than I am right now.
There's that,
Marty was 13 years older than my mom.
My older brother is 10 years older than I am.
So I like,
I grew up with her grandkids.
Um,
and so,
you know,
for me,
like I said,
she's,
she's a very private person.
And so to get that to,
it's not that there was like,
oh,
what this one thing that was so surprising,
it's just,
I mean,
if you think about your,
I assume everyone's relationship with your aunt and uncle,
it's like you don't really sit for hours and talk about like,
what did you and your husband fight about and how did you make up and what did
you,
you know,
and,
and you certainly probably never had to write a sex scene between them.
Um,
uh,
I,
you know,
so and so.
Oh yeah,
guys,
we had a screening the other night in DC and the moderator asked Ruth,
uh,
how she felt about the sex scene.
And she goes,
Marty would have loved it.
I just,
nothing to do with the guy answered your question.
But the really funny,
um,
that is the,
you know,
so it was just a matter of asking the hard questions,
for my wife and I,
you know,
when we got married,
we very consciously said to each other,
what's been like them?
Let's be Ruth and Marty.
Um,
so I was like on this stealth mission to figure out how did they build this
marriage where they were,
not only did they both have incredible careers,
um,
which I think is something we're getting better at these days.
Um,
but they were also equal partners at home or they,
they,
you know,
Marty did all the cooking because Ruth was a god awful cook.
Um,
and,
uh,
but they shared the load of like getting food on the table and taking care of
the kids and getting the kids to school every day and all that.
Um,
and statistically we still suck at that.
and so understanding how they,
how they pulled that off as such,
such confidence
and love and mutual support was,
uh,
was,
was the goal of writing the movie.
Yeah.
Speaking of that scene in the bedroom scene,
why,
why was it important to include that in the movie and why portray this aspect of
her life specifically?
Well,
because everybody has made love since the beginning of time and everyone's human
and everyone makes love.
And it was really important to show her as a real authentic woman.
And it was really interesting though,
not shooting the scene with army and Felicity,
it was cutting the scene that was,
you know,
made me have to think,
cause not,
you know,
I had,
you guys haven't seen the film,
but it's very tame.
It's not even really a love scene.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's very tame.
And I had it far more risky.
Kay.
You know,
I had her sitting on him and I mean it was,
it was it,
they got into it a little and then I was in the end of the room going,
oh no,
I dunno.
I Dunno if RBG well like this
and you do,
her nephew wouldn't have,
he was like,
and it was really interesting.
So it was deeper and more contemporary than it is in the film.
And then I just said,
no,
let's make this really simple and,
and put the point of the story is,
I'm at,
we're at dinner after we showed it to her with this team version and her
biographer,
her official biographer,
what?
Oh my God,
the sex scene was like,
and she goes,
oh,
it's just so much.
And I said,
well,
I was like,
I said,
really?
you should have seen it before.
And then she said to her,
well,
what do you think Ruth?
And every all eyes go to RBG and she goes,
I'm fine with it.
It was really funny.
Anyway,
um,
for,
for Justin,
so I know you and Mimi have worked together before on the leftovers,
but how did you get involved with this project?
Does it through your relation with Mimi or through,
um,
a different sort of avenue in it?
Wa
Yeah,
I mean,
yes,
maybe you sent me the script and said,
you know,
there's this part that I'd love for you to play and Blah,
blah.
So I said,
of course.
I mean,
I read it and then
eventually,
yeah,
he didn't really,
he just read my parts
eventually.
And it sounded cool.
You write in your person on your right.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
a lot of the characters that you've,
you've taken on have been sort of eccentric characters in different ways,
but fictional characters.
What was it like playing someone who,
um,
obviously is a real life person?
Um,
and um,
how did you sort of prepare for the role and,
get to know Mel as a,
as a person?
Give him is an eccentric character.
I mean,
he was at an odd,
I mean duck kind of,
we didn't have any source material on him really.
There was no publicity and army.
We're able to look at photos and videos and,
you know,
hear audio recordings.
We didn't have any of that.
We sort of knew what his trajectory was in his career.
Just,
you know,
there was some newspaper clippings of newspaper clippings.
There was the internet about him.
MMM.
Um,
uh,
so we,
I had got to play around a little bit more,
but he was kind of a controversial figure at the ACLU.
Uh,
and I,
you haven't seen the film,
but he was bit of a misogynist even though he was very progressive and forward
leaning and,
and um,
taking on a lot of very important issues as it relates to sort of constitutional
stuff,
the first amendment and some civil rights issues.
But feminism wasn't really on his radar,
at least advancing it through the ACLU and also didn't have,
I didn't have to do any sort of mimicry,
you know,
to cause we couldn't find the guy frankly.
Right.
Um,
Dustin steals every scene in the movie,
the ones he's in
almost not showing up,
I guess for,
for,
um,
uh,
Daniel.
Mimi,
how,
how true to life was the relationship that you portrayed between Ruth and Marty
and there's so much of it that are these sort of quiet moments of,
of their domestic life,
but then also them sort of pioneering together within the legal profession.
And how much of that was really true exactly to it.
It's based on a true story,
but,
um,
well I would say that,
you know,
um,
the justice was very,
he worked very closely with Daniel and he can speak to that,
that everything she was a stickler on the law and it was,
you know,
not being a family member,
but just being a director in wanting to portray a,
uh,
a marriage that is longstanding and,
and a real equal partner ship.
I really understood that.
And I really,
you know,
when you hire incredible actors,
no matter how incredible you are,
they are,
you never know if it's really going to work.
You never know if the chemistry is going to really hit.
And it did.
And a lot of the relationship is I believe,
really truly authentic in,
in the feelings of love and equal partnership.
And it was important to get the stuff in between the lines,
the looks,
the fields.
Um,
but the lines are pretty good too,
right?
Yeah,
they're okay.
A lot of polishing.
Yeah.
And Martin did bring her the case and it was really important to all of us and
especially RBG to,
to tell the story the way it happened.
And,
and why,
why did you specifically choose this period of her life?
Um,
to focus on and for the film for the screenplay,
um,
because she's obviously had an enormous impactful career across decades,
which was the point she made when I raised it with her.
Actually,
no,
I,
I know,
I heard the story of this case the first time.
Uh,
it was at my uncle's funeral.
A friend of his got up and gave you a g didn't just 2010.
And he mentioned the only case that Ruth and Marty ever argued together and it
was like,
wow,
it's the two of them fighting in court for exactly what figured out how to live
at
home,
real equality.
Um,
and it was the first case she ever argued and it was the first case to convince
the federal court that women should be considered people under the US
Constitution despite the fact that they argued it by representing a man.
Um,
so there was so much about the story that I just thought was fascinating.
I thought this would make a great movie.
And then I thought,
what kind of Asshole am I?
Am sitting here at my uncle's funeral,
mining his life for material that's not like a thing you can do.
Um,
and so I was like,
okay,
clearly I can't write this.
And I sat on it for over a year.
Um,
but then finally I just couldn't stop thinking about it.
And so I called Ruth and I said,
I'd like your permission,
I'd love your help.
And she raised the exact same point.
Did I argued other cases?
I agree.
Bigger cases in cases in front of the Supreme Court.
But once I said,
yeah,
but this is the one that's about you and Marty,
this is a movie about a marriage,
then she,
well,
I was gonna say she got excited about what she actually said was,
if that's how you want to spend your time.
So
fair enough.
That's what they're again for,
for great enthusiasm.
Um,
one of my favorite scenes in the movie was the moot court scene in the home
beforehand.
Um,
I thought it was a really great way to incorporate Murray n to the film as well.
And um,
uh,
and you know,
it hurt her sort of impact as a pioneer in this space is I'm too,
was this something that really happened?
The moot court seemed,
was this space anything or is this completely brought in to sort of show the
dynamic in the
no,
at first I actually,
it was a w I agree.
It's my favorite.
It's my favorite scene in the movie.
Um,
but it,
it came initially just out of like need as a writer because what was happening
in the first draft was,
you know,
like you know that you're getting up to the end towards the third act,
the end of the movie,
you're building it for the climax in court.
We'll see you in court.
And then she goes marching into core and then the whole movie has to stop to
explain how federal court works.
And it was just killing me on the page.
I was like,
yeah,
exactly.
And so what I finally figured out was,
oh,
if I could put in a moot court 20 minutes earlier,
I can teach the audience how this is all going to work so that by the time we
get to the end,
I don't have to stop to explain it all.
Um,
and so it's like w initially it was just like a structural thing to teach the
audience how to keep score during the final scene.
And it's like,
and like,
it's like an Invictus,
that movie about rugby where like they have to stop and explain how rugby works
to the American audience before they,
um,
yeah.
And so that's where it originally came from.
And then out of that,
it just kept all of these more because there's so many characters there,
a male wolf's there,
you know,
being,
being a jerk,
um,
in the most charming way possible.
Um,
you know,
and,
and Ruth and Marty are there and there's,
it's a,
I don't want to spoil the movie,
but it's a huge turning point in the,
in the,
in the film for the older,
she gets on the Supreme Court.
And so it's,
uh,
it's,
it becomes this,
this,
this sort of crucial moment because all of the May,
all the main characters sort of reach a big turning point in their relationships
moving forward into,
in the film.
But it was made up.
Yeah.
But it was really important to the justice to,
um,
have Pauli Murray
in the film and Gerald Gunther,
her teacher,
and Pauli Murray,
you could do a movie just on her alone.
And,
um,
so in that way it was paying tribute and honor to what they had achieved and
done in the civil rights movement.
I think there's something to Bruce credit that you shouldn't give me very many
like big notes about how she wanted the movie to work.
But the one that she gave me was,
well,
the two that you gave me a word,
Marty get Marty.
Right.
And,
um,
and she said,
I just don't want people to think that I invented this area of the law as if it
never occurred to anyone before me,
that women should be considered people under the 14th amendment.
Um,
and,
and she said,
I built my career on the shoulders of women who came before me,
like Dorothy Kenyon and like Pauli Murray and people should know that.
And I'm like,
what am I supposed to do with that note?
And so as you see in the film,
Paulie Paulie's in that scene in Dorothy Kenyon plays a big role played by Kathy
Bates is incredible.
Okay.
So I,
one of the things I noticed a lot was the film portrays,
um,
this really special relationship between mothers and daughters.
Um,
so there's a lot of of Ruth with her daughter,
um,
with,
with Jane and,
but then there's also glances of Ruth at her though her mother's picture and
sort of the thought,
the,
the sentiments from other had shared with her.
And as you were developing some of the dialogs that go on between Jan and Ruth
in the film or though some insights that,
um,
justice Ginsburg had had shared with you or,
or that potentially Jane had as you thought about them?
Or are they sort of just crafted from sort of a lot of them?
I could actually imagine myself,
my myself and my mother sort of having some of those conversations at home.
But um,
for the development side of it,
uh,
no,
I mean the start of the dialogue was,
was real dialogue.
Um,
you know,
it was taken based on research.
I remember at one point I said to my mom,
I was like,
oh,
hey,
I'm having trouble figuring out how to write Jane.
She goes,
oh,
that's easy,
just right Clara,
who's Jane's daughter?
And I was like,
oh,
I know how to do that because they like a family of really strongly opinionated
women,
uh,
who do not hold back.
Um,
uh,
which is what we love about them.
Uh,
most of the time.
And
I,
I will say that right after we saw this vehicle we had,
and we had a screening for the family and we went out for dinner and Clara goes,
mom,
is that what you were like when you were a teenager?
And Jane tried to hedge and she's like,
hesitated for a second route,
just button it goes,
yes.
Yeah,
I think,
I think you know that that dynamic of,
of being a fighter and,
and,
and how you learn it from your parents,
but also you,
you,
you can't like admit that to yourself that you got it from your parents.
I can invite anyone to come up to the mix.
I'll continue to ask some questions,
but if you can make your way up there,
if you have any questions,
how is justice Ginsburg doing these days with her ribs?
She's fantastic.
She has other ribs.
She's already back at work and back in the gym,
so.
Great,
great.
Good to hear.
Uh,
and second,
with this nature of Hollywood coming out with sequels is her life,
I mean,
so grand and so epic,
are we going to see a sequel on the of sex too?
Well,
I'm not writing it.
That's very interesting.
I mean,
I think the other film would be her relationship with,
uh,
Justice Scalia and I think that would be,
that'd be the one that Med [inaudible] story to tell.
Yes.
I got to go right there.
Thank you.
That was a good answer.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um,
I wanted to ask about just kind of the ongoing conversation socially and
politically.
Um,
and I'm sort of,
the creative process took quite a few years and over those period of years the
conversation has really kind of grown as far as,
um,
the women's rights with me too and whatnot.
How did kind of the social escalation of all of these,
uh,
issues either inform or way on your creative process?
Is that me or you or anyone who wants to weigh in?
It was interesting when we were shooting it because you know,
all the,
uh,
you know,
Harvey Weinstein and Kevin Spacey,
all those things were breaking literally around.
So we were all sort of showing up on sets going like I've used red that would
this,
that you have it.
It just felt like there was this avalanche of things happening.
It didn't really,
at least for me,
it didn't really affect what we were doing as far as,
um,
cause the,
we already had our story in place,
you know,
we weren't really changing anything on the fly because some asshole,
got into trouble,
you know.
Um,
so we just sort of kept doing what we were doing.
I mean,
if anything,
it's sort of added to the,
uh,
you know,
we weren't timing this movie with these movements,
you know.
Um,
but,
uh,
of course,
you know,
telling more stories about her life feels more relevant,
uh,
in this time where we feel like we're taking enormous steps backwards,
you know,
or at least the last couple of years
I feel like it changes the experience as a viewer.
Yeah.
Because when I wrote,
when I started this movie in 2011,
I started saying to people,
I'm going to write a movie that Ruth Bader Ginsburg and there,
and be like,
well,
the biggest problem is nobody knows who Ruth Bader Ginsburg is.
And then it's like,
now as you said that she's like this,
she's become this pop icon.
Um,
and,
and that all happened after the movie was written.
Um,
and so it's sort of my experience.
Like,
I thought I was writing to him,
he's going to introduce the world to Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
And then it becomes like a tea,
if you like.
For me now with the movie feels like it's about,
and a lot of ways is,
is it's still about how Ruth,
um,
change the country,
but it's about how she changed the country.
And today we're looking at it in 2018 it becomes about how she changed the
country by convincing people who disagreed with her to agree with her rather
than trying to destroy the people who disagreed with her.
And that feels like now for me as a viewer,
that feels like the poignant lesson of the movie is like there was a time when
we didn't try to destroy each other.
Um,
and maybe we can get back to that if we are willing to like learn what Ruth has
to teach us.
Um,
as you were doing some of the researcher,
as you were putting together the film,
was there anything that you learned about,
um,
justice Ginsberg that you,
during the making that you wanted to include in the film,
but either she see it vetoed or didn't want or that you just couldn't fit in,
um,
to the storyline?
Well,
I should say for the record,
there was never a time that she ever said,
oh,
I don't want that in the movie there was a,
I mean,
the only reason she would do that as if the law is wrong or the way the law was
practice was wrong.
Um,
but she never once gave a note based on Ego,
which is I think really kind of incredible because she went through,
I sent her the script the first time and she's like,
Oh,
Daniel,
I'm in the middle of reading the affordable care act.
Can you call me back in 20 minutes?
And I'm like,
okay,
20 minutes while she was in about 40 minutes that I call her back.
And she's like,
okay,
page one.
And then she goes through it like a contract and she'll be like literally,
I mean like the opening line of the scream fight is like a pair of heels amongst
a sea of loafers.
And she's like,
here on page one you have me wearing a pair of heels.
But in those days I used to walk to Harvard and so I never would have worn heels
and those and I was like,
this is how this is going to go all in.
You know,
like we're going.
Um,
and so and then I then I have to argue it with it,
right?
Cause that's what you want to do is get into a debate with Ruth Bader Ginsburg
or you can win that the yields are in the mood.
I was like,
it's orientation,
it's a special.
Um,
and so,
but uh,
and then we get to like scenes where she,
where she fumbles and I'm going on and know what you're going to do.
This is if we have to go 10 minutes on the heels,
what are we going to do when we get to that?
And she's like,
and skip the next five pages.
And I'm like,
really?
And she said,
yeah.
And I was like,
well,
because you kind of just fumble over here,
I don't know why I decided to negotiate against myself,
but you're going to fall over.
And she goes and she goes,
oh yeah,
it has to be that way.
It's more dramatic.
And you're like,
oh,
okay.
That's nice.
Um,
so you have the heels in the beginning.
One of the things I thought was really poignant but also really interesting in
watching the film is how many moments,
um,
and maybe it's,
maybe it's based on sort of like,
you mentioned this,
this last year of sort of the political discourse and the conversation that's
been heightened.
Um,
but all of the moments where she's the only woman in either literally in the
room or even in,
in the conversation from the opening scene to obviously that the dean's remarks
and Harvard,
um,
the elevator rides up to the interviews.
I mean,
just moment after moment throughout the film.
Um,
I assume that was intentional,
very intentional spotted.
Um,
and it works really well.
There were nine women.
I would only put maybe one or two in the same frame because in a sea of men they
would be just little dots on a map.
Right.
Um,
the,
uh,
the dinner party that is hosted was that,
um,
uh,
something pulled was the dinner party hosted by the dean of Harvard for the,
the ladies as he called them,
who had been accepted that year and quote taking the spots from men.
Um,
was that,
is that sort of verbatim as how it went?
It is exactly.
I've been accused of being heavy handed and writing that same because you'd be
like,
clearly that couldn't have happened.
I'm like,
no,
that's exactly how that went down.
The only thing different from how it happened was we put it at a dining room
table and from what I can gather,
what we can gather,
it was in a room where they were so small table,
but it felt more,
the visual felt stronger to put it on a table because she dropped the ashtray in
real,
in reality.
And it just felt better to drop it off a dining room table where people are
smoking while you're eating,
which
is very 50s
please.
Oh,
thank you.
Yes,
please.
I'd love to hear a bit about the casting process on finding the perfect person
to portray phone with me against mark.
Well,
so we had a list of women who could play RBG and I kept focusing on Felicity
Jones.
I kept looking at the young RBG pictures and Felicity and I felt there was a
striking resemblance and Felicity has a really deep,
deep in her life from what I've seen in her work.
And I felt that she could,
it was just instinct.
You have instinct,
you have to go on your instincts when you're casting because you never really
know.
Sometimes you like,
I knew Justin actually could just inhabit this guy and we don't often see Justin
be this person.
In fact,
I've never seen you be this person.
So I didn't know he could actually do it,
but I,
I knew he could,
if you know what I mean.
I had not seen it before,
but I knew he was the right guy.
And beautifully,
beautifully performed,
but you know,
finding the,
you know,
Felicity Jones was a,
it was a big key.
And we sent her the script on a Thursday to in London and then she replied on
Monday with a yes,
which is very rare in our business and you know,
it takes months for someone to read and someone to agree to something.
And she immediately agreed to it.
And then there was Armie hammer who I,
I've never seen do this kind of role either,
but I had a,
a real desire and hunch that he did that he had it in him because I always
thought he was charming and,
and he,
he never really played a guy like this.
Um,
and he's the only one I wanted.
It was like I was at the agency and they had you go through this process where
the agent show you,
that's horrible to say this in front of an actor.
I know what happened.
They give you all these pictures and resumes and you have your own list anyway,
and you go through them and,
and no,
no,
no.
Yes.
It's horrible too.
But I,
I just knew that army couldn't have at this character and bring his unique charm
and wit to it.
And I also love the height difference.
And I thought that that was,
which isn't accurate because Marty was tall and Ruth is a little tiny,
beautiful woman and I really loved the idea of this kind of frame,
which is really hard to do.
Um,
which goes to picking the format of how you shoot something.
So this was shot in one eight,
five and two.
Three five is a bunch of short,
shorter frame and stretched out and was such a tall person and touch a shorter
person.
You want to have a ratio that's like this and also to fit the supreme court in a
shot.
And how far to back to you put your camera to get this wide shot?
Well,
in format one,
eight five you can do it.
I,
I don't know if that's interesting.
Thank you.
And I,
I just wanted to add,
because I've known Ruth A.
Martin Ginsburg for a very long time,
that they're portrayals of my aunt and uncle are uncanny.
It's really kind of freaky.
A final question for you all.
So,
um,
the film portrays Ruth as this,
uh,
as,
as herself obviously and as a working mother who can kind of do it all.
She's top of her class at Harvard.
She's attending her courses and her husband's courses.
Um,
she's caring for her husband during his illness.
she's raising two children.
She's working a full time job as a professor and in her spare time she sets in
motion to changes that are really reshaping,
you know,
women's rights and human rights.
Um,
what is the message that you're hoping that particularly any viewers,
but particularly women and girls are taking away from this film?
Um,
after they watch it?
Well,
I hope that women and particularly young women take away that they can do
anything.
Women can do anything and um,
that you use your voice to,
to make this world a better place.
I was going to say,
one of the things that I liked so much about,
I don't know what,
you know,
I hope people take away obviously a sort of a renewed or first time or whatever
interest in her life and,
and uh,
and obviously all the things she went on to do.
One of the things I really liked about this,
just as a woman in a film as a lead in the film,
is that,
you know,
oftentimes mothers and or professionals are portrayed as sort of like,
I'm a working mom,
but I can't get work right.
You know,
or like,
but I can't get mothering.
Mothering is,
oh,
well there's just always like,
uh,
given a take,
you know,
it's like,
career is great,
but,
you know,
at home it's a mess and,
we're,
we're homes great and works in math.
And Ruth really didn't really have,
you know,
she just really did everything really well and just by dent of extremely hard
work.
Um,
so I just,
it was,
I haven't really seen that represented so beautifully,
you know,
uh,
in a film before.
So people take away her work ethic and also the fact that she,
she's not,
she hasn't just done an enormous amount.
These are not things that can be undone.
The things she's done.
You know,
when you create a strong case law,
you know,
that's not a,
uh,
a plant.
You can just unplug it and you know,
throw away,
you know,
it's there for good,
you know.
And she did make it a lot of very,
extremely permanent changes in our country.
Yeah.
May I just add one thing to say?
Of course I just wanted to add that.
No,
she didn't do it alone.
You know,
she did it.
That was my thing.
I leave that out,
you know,
interrupted and steal your thing.
Are you saying
I'm not doing that?
Go forward.
Don't slip on that.
Uh,
you know,
that they had an equal partnership.
That was a real metaphor for the film in that,
yeah.
You,
you know,
that love and family are,
are the most important thing and in life is connectivity and how you share your
life and the choices you make,
um,
and choosing the people you love and that love you.
Very important.
Yeah.
As I say,
because that kind of respect,
this agree with the formulation of the question.
It's not that Ruth,
that all those things,
Ruth and Marty did all those things and I can tell you as a guy from experience
the bar to be considered a supportive father and I sort of husband and good
father is like incredibly low.
Like I like take my kids to school everyday and people are like,
you're the best father in the world.
Meanwhile,
my wife's curing cancer and has made to feel guilty that she's not like baking
for bake sales.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I just feel like,
I hope that that's a walk away from the film is that,
you know,
my wife and I were so benefited from having Ruth and Marty's are role models for
what a marriage can be.
Um,
part of the reason for writing this is I realized I was in this privileged
position to share that with other people.
So if nothing else,
the movie is a,
is a great date.
Movie phone is a barometer.
So that,
like if you walk into the theater and the guys like that guy couldn't exist,
like,
just run.
Okay.
Right.
And why is what it is a beautiful love story.
And then also,
you know,
adding on the sort of a monumentous changes that she with others,
um,
helps to put for our country's laws.
It's pretty incredible.
So,
yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you all for coming here today.